In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 20th on which we commemorate, are venerable
Father Athanasios, founder of the monastery of the Transfiguration in the Mithiora and his
successor, the venerable Joseph.
Our Holy and God-bearing Father Athanasios was born about the year 1302 in Neopatras, Ipatia,
in it seems, a rich and noble family, for he never allowed himself to speak of his origins.
Being orphaned, he was brought up by his uncle.
When the city was taken by Alfonso's fatrigues of Aragon, who, at the head of the Catalan
Company, had seized the Latin Duchy of Athens in the years 1317 through 1330, he escaped
with his uncle and found refuge in Thessalonica, possessed by a great desire to learn but not
having the resources to do so, the lad named Andronikos at Holy Baptism, followed philosophy
and classical literature courses by standing at the windows of known teachers of the city,
and they, moved by his zeal, would often agree to teach him without payment.
On a visit to the Holy Mountain, he was greatly edified by the conversations on true philosophy
with the spiritual fathers, but they did not allow him to remain on Mount Athos because
of his youth.
He then went to Constantinople where he venerated the famous sanctuaries and made the acquaintance
of eminent people there, such as St. Gregory the Sinite and St. Isador, the future patriarch
in the years 1347 through 1349, who supported his decision to embrace the angelic life.
Arriving in Crete, he began to lead the ascetic life, but realizing that the admiration of
his patrons would make him fall into the snares of the evil one, he decided to return to
Athos.
He went directly to the skeet of Maguola, one of the high places of Hezekhasm, where
the disciples of St. Gregory counseled him to put himself under the direction of Moses and
Gregory, two elders who were very advanced in virtue, and who lived in a cold, high place
called Milia.
At the age of 30, Andronikos was clothed in the monastic habit under the name of Athanasios,
and saw to all the needs of the two elders with humility and without murmuring, like
a beast of burden, paying no attention to the rigors of the climate or the limits of nature.
The frequent incursions of Turkish pirates obliged these lovers of Isihia to leave their
cell.
Moses retired to the monastery of Ividon, Gregory, Athanasios and another disciple left for
Beria.
Yet, the frequent visits of Lafalk was an obstacle to their desire for solitude, and on
the recommendation of James, a disciple of the Sinite, who had become Bishop of Serbia,
they retired to Thessaly, near the town of Stagai, Kalambaka, where great majestic and wild
rocks arose, a thousand feet sheer, which seemed to have been placed there by the creator
from the creation of the world as an ideal setting for monastic life.
They settled themselves on a rock named The Pillar, near the town, where a church cut out of
the rock and dedicated to the archangels already existed.
Gregory, fearful of the harshness of the place, and the difficulty of finding food, wanted
to find a better place, but Athanasios urged him to have patience in order to protect
their Iihia.
The presence of the ascetics soon drew a great number of the faithful to the place, Avid
for spiritual counsel, and some of them became monks.
Athanasios then obtained permission to retire for five days of the week to be with God without
distraction.
He settled in a cleft in the rock, where he persevered in continual prayer, plating wool
in order to fight Iihia, sloth.
He repeated constantly, watch O my soul, so as to be saved, and you, my body, work to feed
yourself.
Perseverance in vigils allowed him to conquer the tyranny of sleep, and often during his
prayer, he found himself carried off into ecstasy, of which, however, he never spoke to his disciples.
One night, Gregory saw the demons who were hurling themselves at Athanasios' retreat in
order to cast him into the void.
He therefore prevailed on him to return to community life, but, disturbed by the noise occasioned
by the close proximity of the town, Athanasios went to settle in a quieter place, lower down
the mountain, and only returned to the others for the Sunday Vigil service.
But there, as well, he was unable to enjoy the hessikast life, as thieves came to pillage
his hermitage.
He therefore asked his elder to allow him to take refuge on the rock, which dominated
the others, at the summit of which was a large plateau, suitable for monks to settle.
Gregory, who wanted to make Athanasios his successor, hesitated at first, but finally agreed,
on condition that he was accompanied by two other monks.
They therefore settled on the rock, which they called the Mitheor.
In two caves, one of which became a church dedicated to the mother of God.
Ten years after he had settled on the pillar, Gregory, worn down by the pressures of the local
authorities, decided to return to Constantinople, his homeland.
Later he found his blessed rest, edifying all the devout people of the capital by his virtues.
Athanasios designated a superior for the community of the pillar, and would only allow fourteen
monks to remain with him on the medire.
Those who were capable of leading a life of great austerity, and whom he named the Parageliotis.
Soon, however, he was forced to concede that several of the ascetics were not able to contend
themselves, with Mary's part of prayer and contemplation.
He therefore organized them into a xenobitic community, according to the model of the
tipicone of the monasteries of Mount Athos, and had a church built for them, dedicated to
the transfiguration.
He urged them to live in unity, with a single will, to share food and clothing, and to renounce
all personal property, even a thing so small as a needle.
To gather together in the church for the daily services, this xenobitic community organized
on the stable foundations of the tradition of the Holy Fathers drew an increasing number
of disciples, not only layfolk, but also monks, who left their hermitages on Athos to put
themselves under the direction of Saint Athanasios.
The latter taught them the art of arts, and used the grace of discernment that God had given
him to lead them on the path of salvation.
He also had received the gift of prophecy, and predicted the death of St. Joseph's mother,
as well as the unsuccessful attack on Thessalonica by the Turks in the year 1372, three years
in advance.
Avid, however, to preserve his beloved Isihia, he appointed his disciple Gregory, as
general administrator of the monastery.
On the death of this latter, the direction passed to the Hyromunk Makarios, and then to Agathon,
who had come from Mount Athos with his disciples.
When he died, Saint Athanasios 78 years old, ill and forseeing his own close departure, designated
the Prince monk Joseph to succeed him.
At the end of a 40-day illness, he was reunited to the choir of the Holy Fathers in the
year 1380, but he did not cease to watch invisibly during the centuries over the monasteries
of this new Thabayid.
Our Holy Father Joseph was named John Urosh Paleologos in the world.
His father, Simeon Urosh, was descended through his paternal family from the illustrious
Serbian Nemanjid dynasty.
On the death of his brother, Stephen Dushan, in the year 1331 through 1356, he had refused
to recognize the successor to the throne of Serbia, and had constituted a pyrus and Thessaly
into a separate kingdom with Thrikala for its capital.
On his death in the year 1371, his son John was forced to take up the succession, however,
he, avid even on earth for the kingdom of heaven, preferred to dawn the rough habit of
a monk, rather than the royal purple.
He left his kinsmen Alex Andeolos Filantropinos at the head of his kingdom, and rejoined St. Athanasios,
with whom he had been linked for years in spiritual friendship.
When St. Athanasios fell ill, Joseph had left the media and was on Mount Athos, but after
his death, he assumed the succession, gave the monastery the gift of many precious objects,
and thanks to the help of his sister Angelina Dukaspeljologina, the widow of Thomas Preliobovic,
despot of a pyrus, he finished the Catholicon, and built cells, and all the buildings necessary
for the functioning of a large monastery in the year 1388.
The threat of Turkish incursions forced him to leave the meteor with other monks to
take refuge in the monastery of Atoperi on Athos.
The danger once passed, he returned to his rock between heaven and earth in the year 1401,
where he peacefully completed his earthly soldier in the year 1423.
Like St. Athanasios, St. Joseph had refused to be ordained priest, and instead of becoming
abbot, had himself called Father of the Mithiora.
Besides St. Athanasios and Joseph, the other known saints from Mithiora are Daniel the
Stylite in the 17th century, Nikodimos Monk and Marder of the 16th century, Nektarius and
Thilfanes, founders of Barlam, Benedict their disciple, Maximus and Joseph, the founders
of Rusano in the 16th century, Gregory and Thildosios, the founders of St. Gregory in the 14th
century, Nilos the friend of God in the 14th century, the founder of the Hippapante, Antony
in the 14th century, and Philothios in the 16th century, the founders of St. Stephen's Dionysius
the merciful Bishop of Larissa in the 16th century, and Nikonor, Exarch of Stagui in the
16th century, the founders of St. Nicholas and Appasas, through the prayers of our Holy
Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and save us.